we're going slow with the last main
teaching point I wanted is that you're
not just hitting
I understand it seems to be human nature
so what I mean is you take turns
it reminds me of when my brother not as
kids with no training no combat
experience would pretend that we're
doing that do you understand so you guys
all taking turns that translates
infallibly
as you are waiting for each other to
complete the move that is I don't even
know how that would work
it's not in your body art we don't stand
still
they're moving we're moving we're not
waiting okay so as he moves you see how
I'm already moving you guys all do this
we're already moving he moved to do that
you don't have to pick it up
that's me to pick it up but you have to
be in this relationship with him
[Music]
so what
just watch my torso forget to Joe booze
we get the joke you go but they're gonna
watch my words are not the joke
Bonnie's movie go go Oh bodies
[Music]
move increase your mobility singing
don't confuse training vectors with
Marshall chocolates so that's what he
goes and now you guys next move I can
make this first joke line and training
vector so we start over
and that was honesty it's a line that I
work to keep my line
he says marginally liked it and that's
his job and I'm blocking it
he's gotta wait there for me
also in terms of hidden dog his Jo's out
in the middle if his jokes out in the
middle my jaw should not be speaking the
middle that's a younger young class go
back my toaster go back slower his Joe
goes back I just never not his choice
coming out my moves out his Joe moves
back move right his Joe takes the line
my Joe takes the curve
y'all get different that's a training
vector before we go this is training
bender okay he goes OH
second one here when you guys come here
you're going like this stop the fight
stop the fight till the fight and let's
look at this vector Roxy I'm here I go
what's that problem again we describe it
in the terms I just gave you anyway
Here I am
he goes we're meeting in the middle
watch he goes my trip goes to the middle
when his hotel
I'm not waiting there so he's there I
followed it and as you're doing that hey
starting to fill up
withdraw good we go this is part of that
concept I'm this inning six so I don't
have to worry about the other range some
of you are crossing the circle in
punching range like you okay so like
this way we even drop the weapon this is
not a freebie
you have to get just like all the other
techniques behind that rear corner so as
he withdraws whoa I'm protecting all
that as I'm going around right not here
he's so long he could just smack me oh
so you're here he goes moving out of
that ring that's why I have a long
weapon okay let's go
[Music]
she's finally learn more okay is she
ever going to learn the floor okay let's
not make it we let's just go I'm doing
the dance teacher said step there this
way at that time but okay so we'll go to
the first one training better trained
better stay there my weapon fine to this
angle this angle is the shielding angle
you see that okay it's not here it's not
here
it's cutting across multiple planes it's
the same thing punches oh you have this
shielding angle you get it alright maybe
then you'd find your track piece so I'm
not blocking his fire
we go go training vector it's here it's
not here
that's not a shielding anything because
it's too weak 45 if you had come down it
would spill off the bottom when I do
this it hits it's too weak and it
doesn't die the way you understand and
it's not covering my body I'm hiding
here in that plane it's the one that
comes around boom today everyone ah yes
okay now what I asked you to do is to
stop making the first skier training
better and to look at the body but it's
the same
don't start going like this
we're gorgeous where's your shoes Oh
what if we change it last second what if
he goes home you got nothing
so as I'm moving is that same angle
somebody do now are going like this
that's not hang he goes
this one will be training better not
going to happen yet Oh make sure you get
a full speed you were a really
impressive here whoa here we go the
harder training backs you know you want
to touch my toes my job get around
and hit me in the head but I ski same
shield yes but now we drop drop low you
guys so do it again
Ian up don't get ready to run around me
all right you might end it right there
you still wanna touch my job hi you want
to touch you attention
yeah
we don't have to see that if I was
beaten up but you've got not maybe so
I'm going to cash flow are you gonna
push it push it right but why what what
happened to Canada
do you take your seminar guy get it back
to indicat live in Oslo
you do go back
drop it drop it right there
hey now do it again
keep it up
[Music]
different okay now you do that with the
weapon got it I don't care about him
he's a joke why do I care about his job
I'm not there
[Music]
that's where you're open to that
sidekick
[Music]
still ahead of me what the to be nothing
just work on getting behind I don't care
the drops you don't use it just get
behind me
forget the strike look at me now bring
the flip maneuvers in and the range okay
now
[Music]
again slow okay let's get rid of that
beat you go as slow as you want I just
have to keep
you got you it's got all work like snot
whatever like slow I'm sick what I'm
trying to tell you you're going too fast
for your processing ability move no
don't ready ready to take off yeah come
to the shield position slow slow
hold on your whole body go Boston right
go in slow ok so now I'm not waiting but
I'm training slowly this always causes
another problem in the beginner not
experienced with finals
you can now came the floor mats the
beginner you're like well they're
already that far ahead but we don't see
that in real violence people commit they
don't even II D Utley press the button D
commit and then recommit so boys OODA
loop is all based on that every thing we
head into in law enforcement is based on
that so she's not supposed to wait for
me but she has to push the dot that
angle so I go
she gets the angle you waited for me the
Jo is going backwards
so which wasted your Jo go first Kim to
opening Joe's going backward yes
[Music]
yes that's not stick to the form it's
the only way the floor makes sense you
have to have a commitment to what you're
doing
otherwise why are you super backwards
Steve have committed the body has to
intimidate I wish you to think of it
that way so she gives the opening I'm
not out of there it's not a freaking
lightsaber she gives the opening and I'm
in here they see our eyes widen and her
nostrils flare this is yesterday's
training so my fuse with my body this
thing not just this chest but this heart
inside everything it would I do that I
can't go so we're going slow it's a good
time to practice that investment of
heart body school she goes now here's
our second problem when you put that
first column on hold you're not
practicing your commitment second
problem you're going for this range and
this foot is moving backwards of its
location this way further west well
right so that unity has
right but this is a training vector
right this strike on the ass happens
over here say there so the strike things
in here cannot hit up there without
changing the power line so here's where
I am now we go back to the first problem
if I was too aggressive and I'm trying
to intimidate you
I cannot go backwards and I would not
want to I want to keep pressing
so as my beam comes in I never get so
again you're doing weird that step
back is hitting sticks not actually
committing so follow my rule because we
are keeping it a training factor that
foot cannot go back in the direction you
came from so I go one she's there that
foot has to move away from that wrong
he's saying this all happens much closer
than where you want it to be because
we're running into problems go back
rewind the zone holy cow you're gonna
fight her all mentally tougher because
i've already pushed on you so even with
this slow pace and that's what you try
to do fast
[Music]
so we go one whoa okay here we are
but you guys want to be here you see and
now when you ski you're not committed
right you're out here like that and
again I would just go off his back
random interface my attention should be
keep the original onslaught so my body
is moving moving in can you see that yes
body being so if you see where I am
right here at the end you guys are all
here then she does the little scheme and
there's no reason to go around anything
so let's slow it down focusing on this
role and it's one aggression after the
other continual pressure and penetration
school and the jumps the stops and ever
words how much you do with your weapon
it's more this I took off the last move
this is another reason why people hits
it because the thorn keeps going on and
say you go I got another move to do so
you have ax your move and when you mash
your move you violate martial principle
you also are not seriously training you
get to do things with half your ass okay
so we take the last move up I am NOT
going around her I don't have any
intention to
okay it's no different then th at UCI
[Music]
that's in my way get your weapon that
weapons in my way it gets out of my way
my home being aggressive whoo it goes
I'm not gonna pull that you see she went
she's gone again at that point and I
know it so I feel like her I'm not
taking Mexico back I'm not getting ready
to go here she made me go there
that's the forms not making me go there
she's making me go there so in order to
make me go there I'm gonna make her go
got it
so I get it it's no different than
see see go touch the base who she goes
by the punishment I see same thing why
he went by I'm if I stay there
got it so I'm kind of shy she finally
got people possible why I gotta go
around we're gonna shake positions so it
would be like Perry
boom I'm here I'm not going up in her
it's gonna get it get me going
right so on my part
full penetration it out of the way
bye-bye not Barney brush Barney grass
sword and grass okay let's go